OK, so let's continue with our tour of yesterday's
White House Corona virus press briefing.
I already went over parts, I guess, A and
B or one and two with you.
Number one, Donald Trump said.
Why do people like Dr. Foushee?
But they don't like Trump.
Why does Dr. Foushee have a high approval?
And Trump has a low approval when Foushee
works for Trump.
Trump couldn't understand it.
It was really, really weird.
Also yesterday and we already went over this
in the last segment.
Donald Trump told a black reporter, I believe
maybe the one black reporter in the room that
he looks like nearly 80 year old Jewish man,
Michael Bloomberg.
So that was weird in its own way.
But none of that is as crazy as what we're
now going to talk about.
Trump almost seems normal in those instances
compared to what I'm going to talk about now.
Donald Trump Junior was temporarily limited
on Twitter yesterday because he shared a video
of a doctor named Stella Emanuel, who spoke
in favor of hydroxy chloroquine for Corona
virus and believes having sex with demons
can cause illness and believes there's a plan
to vaccinate Americans from becoming religious.
That be an interesting vaccine?
And Donald Trump shared the exact same video
of Stella Emanuel to his 84 million Twitter
followers, but later took it down once the
you know what started to hit the fan.
Now, to avoid problems ourselves, I'm not
going to play the video for you, but you can
find the video easily if you want to.
The same doctor, Stella Emanuel, said you
don't need to wear a mask, which is actually
dangerous disinformation.
She also said that there is already a cure
out there for coronavirus.
So Trump was asked about her during the press
briefing.
This is a really good video you're going to
hear.
CNN reporter Caitlyn Collins lists some of
the things that Stella Emanuel said and believes.
And Trump doubles down.
Check this out.
And then when Caitlyn Collins tries to follow
up, Trump triggered ends the press briefing
immediately and walks out of the room.
He said, isn't great, doctor.
And that video that you retweeted last night
said that masks don't work and there is a
cure for the 90s, both of which health experts
say is not true.
She's also made the news saying that doctors
make medicine using DNA from aliens and that
they're trying to create a vaccine to make
you immune from becoming religious.
Just maybe a shot, but I can't.
I can tell you this.
She was on air along with many other doctors.
They were big fans of hydroxy chloroquine.
And I thought she was very impressive in the
sense that from where she came, I don't know
which country she comes from.
But she said that she's had tremendous success
with hundreds of different patients.
And I thought her voice was an important voice.
But I know nothing about her classmate.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you.
Now, I'm going to admit something to you yesterday,
throughout the day.
I sort of heard rumblings about Don Junior
was limited on Twitter for sharing some video,
but I was busy preparing the show, the podcast,
etc..
And then I heard something about demons, sperm.
Trending on Twitter.
But I was busy preparing for my livestream.
And so I didn't really follow the story closely.
You know, you hear about demon sperm.
I didn't know it was related to Don Junior
didn't pay much attention.
I thought, well, demon sperm must be some
lighthearted story.
Maybe it's something from a video game.
Who knows?
And then meanwhile, Don Junior was limited
on Twitter.
I thought maybe there's a comedic element
here.
There's a meme element.
A joke.
I don't know.
I didn't consider for a second that the entire
thing could have been related to something
that Donald Trump was promoting himself.
She believes in daemonic sperm that can cause
gynecological problems.
And that's who Donald Trump is saying has
a voice that should really be heard on the
issue of Corona virus and on the issue of
hydroxy chloroquine.
This is also intense.
By the way.
Yesterday, Stella Emmanual tweeted out an
article written about her in The Daily Beast.
Look at what she wrote.
She tweeted, quote, The Daily Beast did a
great job summarizing our Deliverance Ministry.
And I hope you're sitting down and exposing
Incubus and Succubus.
Thank you.
Daily Beast, if you need deliverance from
these spirits, contact us.
Deliverance Ministry one.
She seems to be promoting almost like an exorcism
of some kind.
Show us the alien DNA.
She is show us the vaccine that, by the way,
a vaccine to prevent people from becoming
religious would be very interesting in a number
of ways.
The country may be better off if such a vaccine
actually existed on the net.
Now, I know that I'm not saying all religion
is bad or anything like that, but on the net,
we might be better off with such a vaccine.
Imagine a press.
Imagine anyone calling this woman a highly
respected doctor whose voice is important.
Then realize that it's the president of the
United States who is doing it.
So what I want to think about is, is Trump
this stupid or does Donald Trump just prioritize
angering the left?
And remember, prior to Trump ism, the three
main wings of the American right were small
government type liberty folks.
You know, people like in the Tea Party and
the little more libertarian minded, the low
tax, pro-business conservatives like Mitt
Romney is an example who aren't the most socially
conservative people, but sometimes they are.
But it's really not as much about socialist
issues as it is about low taxes and a pro-business
environment.
And then the third wing would be the religious
conservatives, whose priority is often evangelical
Christians who care the most about abortion,
social issues, gay marriage, etc..
Under Trump ism, there's this fourth wing
and it's a wing that, as I discussed yesterday
with Kohlman Hughes, it's not really about
policy, it's about angering the other side.
And so is that what Trump is fundamentally
doing here and kowtowing to and placating
Jews if the left thinks this woman's crazy,
that I should defend her?
And is it as simple as that?
Or does Trump genuinely think that this is
somebody that should be listened to?
I mean, I just don't get it.
I don't I don't really know what's but what
what this is all about.
And it's always easy to say it's meant to
be a distraction.
It's meant to be a distraction from the corona
virus death toll, which spiked over twelve
hundred yesterday for the first time in a
while.
Or it's meant to be a distraction from the
fact that Trump's losing every poll or, you
know, you can always say it's a distraction,
but I think that there's probably some deeper
explanation or understanding that we could
have here.
Insane.
Absolutely insane.
And I don't have the clip.
But I guess today when Trump was doing the
helicopter press conference, just as he was
walking out to his chopper, he was asked again
about this doctor, Stella Emanuel, and like
tripled down on it, although I haven't seen
that video yet.
I will take a look at it.
Let me know what you think explains what's
going on here.